when it comes to traveling
most people take photos and post them on
Facebook some people write blogs I make
videos in review it's pretty much the
way I do things so for two months I
traveled and I observed and pretty much
did whatever you may think of this as a
blog meets documentary or a blog you
mentary copyright 2013
but whatever you may call it these are
my experiences
near my mate press traveled out from our
small city of Perth stralla
although out to Bali it's a common place
for the people of Perth to go because
it's cheap and straightforward to travel
to use to straight up north we started
things off a bit slow with a bit of
relaxation but of course there are still
the occasional moments of craziness but
barley was a good time and was good to
just get away from things just for a
while
enough of that on to the main events the
United States of America our first city
was Los Angeles the city of dreams the
City of Angels were just a big city with
a population of 3.8 million our first
interaction with anyone was our taxi
driver he was talkative as most taxi
drivers are and he was a good guy he got
talking about his life and we ended up
asking if we liked his job his response
was that he had no choice he used to
have a high-profile job but with the
downturn of the economy was forced into
driving taxis he still told us his hopes
and dreams to one day drive to his own
country the economy was the issue on
everyone's lips everywhere you turned
you could hear people talking about it
there was a lot of uncertainty people
just aren't sure when things just going
to get back to normal but realistically
speaking 60 trillion dollars of debt
isn't something akin to sweep under the
carpet things are starting to collapse
and people are feeling the effects be
enough about that back to LA
la a place where Segway still exists and
so do rollerblades a city where anything
and everything happens all at once it's
a city of contrasts on the one hand you
have areas such as the Hollywood Hills
and Venice Beach serene and pleasant but
you step over a few streets and then you
find the homeless the homeless situation
on the west coast is the worst in the
country but more on that later
and I'm not sure if it's the crack
epidemic of the 80s all over again but
la houses a lot of the clinically insane
for example there's this guy that we
found shouting to himself as across the
street and no there's nothing underneath
that skirt these are just my
observations as a foreigner and I'm
really not trying to offend anyone but
anyway let's see what some of the locals
have to say about their city well
always something get into
I don't know what else maybe
but this colorful
but with the snow one
and what with
yeah
singer here
opportunity here
la is huge and you'll definitely need a
car to get around for sure there's no
real city center and the whole city is
kind of just sprawled out all over the
place
so if it's your first introduction to
the USA it could be a bit overwhelming
at first and then of course you have the
whole celebrity aspect to it such as the
Hollywood Walk of Fame in Hollywood
Boulevard it was a bit tacky to be
honest and a lot of fake people around
in general but some people can be into
that kind of thing I'll just take this
opportunity to outline some of the
things that struck me the most about the
USA in general there's much more choice
and many more avenues to go down but
life is definitely harder here I met a
guy in Savannah who had two of his
friends shot and killed in the past two
months but we'll get to that story a bit
later the city itself I didn't really
admire to be honest in saying that I had
some of the coolest times of my trip
there let me tell you why we were
staying on North Fairfax in West
Hollywood
and there I met Josh from Sweden he was
probably one of the most down-to-earth
people I've ever met I whatever you're
ready that I had figured I would think
Hotel easier to say what I liked about
it how well as it turns out Josh's
girlfriend knows some of the band
members from the Swedish band Emmanuel I
happen to sample one of their songs in a
song I put together after which the lead
singer added me on Facebook cutting to
the chase there's a small chance that he
could be watching this very video little
things like this kept happening
throughout my trip and it kind of
reminded me how small the world is
actually getting well as they Amsterdam
but that's love cuz the lead
actual slice okay
I'm Josh I'm Sweden my favorite place
I'm travel to I'm safe Bernie Canada
it's awesome they have a lot of snow in
the summer it's really really hot and
this is Jenna Josh and Jenna randomly
met at a local juice bar they both
happen to order the same drink and they
both hated it they both got talking
about their mutual hate for this drink
and the rest is history
we all ended up getting acquainted and
Jenna decided to show us a night
festival in downtown LA yep
downtown LA the place where you do not
go as a tourist I was a bit nervous at
first but I thought I'd take my chances
I thought it was pretty incredible how a
local could take some time out of their
day and throw some random dumb tourists
around their city no one in their right
mind in Perth would ever do that so at
this point I realized that I was kind of
wrong about my stereotypical assumptions
of the American people we took a bus and
a train and arrived downtown and about
narrow so
I can cut down and structure I can be
offer different cultures by this one
and I love that I can move each step so
with the head I love that smell
that I can dress like a freaking dumb
because what I hate about I hate that
smells like this we got
I hate after the girls are really
as expected
of painters downtown LA wasn't that bad
at all there's only one car chase and no
shootings while were there in general we
all got along pretty well which amazed
me Josh and Gina both love photography
they even happened to have the same old
school film camera I would often say
that extra thought that Gina was
thinking and all four of us loved music
Gina was the worst tour guide ever but
she was cool about it we finally found
the galleries and got to know some of
her local mates as well
showing people this is Gina's friend
will what do you like best Minnesota
what do you think that like best the
sandwiches Sam we do for and what do you
like miss better than we like lease it
out of it we have some pretty fun
moments in a few short days that we hang
out it was all very new for me so that's
why I think it was such a great start to
my American experience we also caught up
with Adam my mate from Perth for a Jay
Leno Show but unfortunately he had a bad
case of the liquid thunder so no footage
of him exists well I think this la cat
is telling us to move on to the next
city
words can't be strong
the stream
we caught a bus and a train from Los
Angeles to San Francisco in what was a
650 kilometers seven-hour journey I took
this time to think of what could be in
store for the rest of the trip as we
left the train and look for a taxi
I had a pressing feeling something was
wrong and I couldn't put my finger on it
turns out that I had actually left the
bass guitar that I had bought in LA on
the train San Francisco population of
800,000 in the Sunshine State it turns
out that we got along so well with Josh
that he decides to book a few extra
nights in the hostel that we had already
pre booked in San Fran I really did like
the city and I do recommend that you
should check it out if you're anywhere
along the west coast
it's mix of quaint architecture with
rampant Hills and great scenery it's a
great place to just take a bike and ride
around which is exactly what we did
the locals are friendly and also good
nature
and of course there's a famous Golden
Gate Bridge which is actually red as we
approach the bridge on our bikes looking
out over the bay was a pretty reflective
experience
built in 1937 the 2.7 kilometer long 27
meter wide 227 meter tall bridge is an
engineering marvel said that 1.2 million
steel rivets hold the structure together
it's no wonder the black path turns into
a mini freeway of design with tourists
as he looked out over the edge of the
bridge it was clear that this afternoon
would stick in my mind for a long time
so what about the nightlife in short
pretty girl we're lucky enough to party
with the NBA team Miami Heat it just
happened to be two of the players
birthdays at the club we were at in a
set of strange events I got led him for
free and one of the players told the
bouncer that I was actually with him I'm
not making this up it was pretty funny
and definitely pretty sweet but he
abandoned me immediately though at night
San Fran has a bit of a buzz about it
probably not as much as some of the
larger cities but the city is still
alive with buskers and performers and
general atmospheres
later on we made it out to Alcatraz you
know that famous unescapable prison of
the 36 people that attempted to escape
23 were caught six was shot and killed
two drowned and five are listed as
missing hmm the prison itself was pretty
cool because I was left largely as it
would have been in the early 60s from
the prison you get a perfect view of San
Francisco City it was said that this was
to let the prisoners know what they were
missing out on each and every day it was
also said that if the wind was blowing
just right you can hear the sounds of
the city such as music and even laughter
a city that has a darker side the
homeless situation in San Francisco is
more pronounced than anywhere else the
milder weather makes straight living
more manageable I really wanted to see
what it was like so I grabbed my camera
and hit the back streets
I got hassled for having a camera a few
times so I had to move quickly
it was definitely disheartening to see
and I really hope the city finds a
solution soon
with the economy being the way that it
is it is probably going to take some
time
Godspeed San Fran
leaving on a positive note San Francisco
was definitely one of my favorite cities
you'll find that most people that have
ever been there would say the same
also I think the San Fran cat is telling
us it's time to move on
we took a quick flight further up north
still to Vancouver Canada and it's true
what they say those Canadians are
actually really friendly and really
chilled out ironically a medic Canadian
whose dream travel destination was
actually barley the city itself was
stunning just picture built-up urbanized
areas and some of the most amazing
snow-capped mountains as a backdrop in
one of my random walks down Vancouver's
main streets I came across a band called
sons of Granville the band was named
after Vancouver's main strip Granville
Street
I caught up with a violinist after the
show hi my name is Thomas Beckman
my band is underground we just played
what I love about Vancouver well I love
the nature I love the fact we're close
to the sea in the mountains I think one
thing I love about Vancouver is it's
very new city and it's like it's like a
blank app we do whatever you want buy a
lot of freedom
unfortunately there's no cat here to
tell us to move on to the next scene we
flew across country all the way to New
York now I'm going to say this now if
you're starting to get tired of watching
this don't fear I'm just going to be
going over the city quickly and then
I'll spend 10 to 15 seconds on each of
the rest of the cities that I visited
and then we'll wrap it up before that
let's take a quick break before we hit
the Big Apple
New York City with a population of 8.4
million the most highly populated city
in the whole of the United States all of
those people are squished into the size
of 800 square kilometers this brings
about the famous melting pot effect
every type of person on earth can be
found here I was pretty excited to
finally reach the ceiling I've heard so
much about and seen in so many movies so
many times once I got another that was
time to grab my camera and explore
unfortunately we've arrived in one of
the most coldest days of the year it
dropped to 12 degrees Fahrenheit or
minus 11 degrees Celsius while we were
there that in itself would have been
fine but the wind was very strong so no
matter how many layers you chucked on
top the cold just cut straight through
the wind chill factor drove the
temperature down to something like minus
26 degrees Celsius you could hear the
locals cursing on their phones about how
cold it was to the person on the other
end of the line despite this we hit up
the famous Times Square and while we're
there we saw saying pretty strange
that's right I don't know if you can see
but there's a man playing guitar and
seeing in nothing but a cowboy hat and
jocks nobody was quite sure how this guy
was still alive but nonetheless are
still pretty entertaining to see the
city itself is very diverse and I think
that's one of the coolest things about
it you can walk a few blocks in the city
centre and be faced with a completely
different look and feel and as usual we
met some pretty awesome people at our
hostel
as a side point I did really like the
subway system it was clear robust and
simple I guess you'll need a system like
that to move 8.4 million people around
my only complaint really was the smell
but apart from that it was intuitive and
easy to get around it took a quick look
around the Bronx and I don't know if you
know but in the late 70s the Bronx was
the dingy estab holes a wave of arsons
swept through the area and it was said
that though as many as 60 fires burning
per day this was most famously
highlighted in the 1977 World Series
when the TV cameras panned away from the
stadium and focused on the burning
skyline since then the Bronx has been
tainted with this image but in the last
10 years there's been a lot of
development and it's really come up a
bit you still do have to watch out at
neither and of course
we all remember those events swellview's
there we went to power respects at the
memorial and you can clearly see that
there's still a lot of pain after more
than a decade later the rebuilding
continues in the form of 540 metre tall
one World Trade Center will be completed
in late 2013 and is currently the
tallest building in New York while they
could still see some signs of damage
from Hurricane sandy but the city is
strong and has rebounded quickly as you
may have guessed I didn't touch on
everything I missed out the beautiful
Central Park Statue of Liberty Empire
State Building and a lot more you need
at least a week to see everything but
New York is definitely a must-see city
okay so now it's time to speed things up
a bit and we're going to do that with a
little thing called from TV Kentucky is
basically a tour where with the group of
people and infest eight different cities
within the country our tour consists of
50 people and we travel to 16 cities in
26 days so as I said I've spent 10 to 15
seconds in each city and then we'll wrap
it up if this concept sounds fun that's
because it is Kentucky was one of the
most insane times I've had in my entire
life after New York was Washington DC
the nation capital there was a fair bit
to see him do here monuments museums art
galleries was actually pretty
interesting and I learnt a lot in my
time there the city was awesome one of
the cleanest that I had been to and I
did enjoy it quite a bit we stayed the
night in Cary and then drove down to
Savannah where I met two locals chip and
Joel chips friend was shot in a case of
mistaken identity
the last words he said to chip we're IOU
on another one of chips friends was shot
in the carjacking chips other friend
Joel argued that people need guns in the
US and told me a story of how an
unloaded gun saved his life from a
mentally unstable person threatened his
life for the knife me and chip ended up
jamming outside my hotel till 6:00 in
the morning from Savannah we stayed a
night in st. Augustine Cocoa Beach and
then drove to Miami Miami was a
good-looking city and it was one of my
favorites seeing something like a
Ferrari or a Bentley wasn't a rare sight
there was a large Spanish population and
it seemed to be stuck in the 80s in the
sense that having a lot of wealth and
power was the in thing to do we drove up
to Orlando and checked out Universal
Studios and it just blew past all my
expectations even if you like me and not
so much into theme parks if you get a
chance go go go
it is amazing we drove to Tallahassee
and then up into New Orleans New Orleans
was a demographically poorer city and
Hurricane Katrina damage was still
evident but the people there had soul
sleep always right here what I love me
about most from here one reason welcome
y'all we love our city and they're
pretty proud about the culture they have
as well we arrived at a pretty good time
we arrived during Mardi Gras and for
Australians watching Mardi Gras isn't
the gay and lesbian festival like it is
in Australia it's actually more along
the lines of Carnival in Rio so
basically just a big blowout party where
people dress up and go crazy
New Orleans was also a very musical city
and speaking of music we drove out to
Memphis there we visited Graceland the
house of Elvis Presley we also went to
where it all began
sand studios
I then finished off the afternoon with a
jam at the Gibson Factory we continued
to Dallas Texas right in the heart of
the south we took a day trip out to Fort
Worth and it's exactly how Texas looks
in the movies the CBD aerial is much
more built up than I had expected and as
they say everything is bigger in Texas I
went out to see the JFK museum it was
very well done and quite intense until
that point I really didn't know how much
JFK had done for the country back in
that era as it turns out he was
assassinated from that very window the
one on the mid ride back in 1963 or was
he there are several witnesses that have
never been shown on national TV and this
lady took film
the old rate for downstream is
to film the grassy knoll from high
elevation
and she said she saw smoke
the first one interviewer my name is
Marcos we spend a lot of years
interviewing people who traveled out of
Dallas to Amarillo and then on to
Albuquerque and rode some hot-air
balloons at dawn
and then those colorado Salalah is just
chilling out at the lodge I had an
interview with one of the non
Australians on Contiki yeah yeah okay my
name is Serena I'm 24 years old I'm from
Switzerland and
Radio Soviet and it's so much fun
what I love in Switzerland is the
mountains
as we drove out to the Grand Canyon I
began to realize that this whole
adventure was going to end pretty soon
everyone in our group was really cool
and got along extremely well our tour
guide said that our group was one of the
best he'd ever had I took a helicopter
ride over the Grand Canyon and let's
just say however big he thought the
Grand Canyon is is nothing compared to
its real size our final stop and grand
finale was none other than Las Vegas and
well let's just say whatever happens in
Vegas stays in Vegas
really but here's what I can reveal huh
Las Vegas was crazy off the charts over
the top and whatever other words you can
use to describe that vibe it had literal
palaces fitted with Greek style column
structures complete with fake skies
painted on the interior ceiling Vegas is
ridiculous it's the closest thing you'll
get to another world everything is done
to perfection and to the extreme the
interiors have fitted out with the
craziest of expensive ornaments the
casinos are always buzzing regardless of
the time of day or even the day of the
week you'd often see the occasional high
roller decked out in the most expensive
attire a symbol of what Las Vegas stands
for there's just so much money pouring
through here it's just hard to get your
head around by the night the city shifts
into seventh gear and things get even
crazier let's just say both nights spent
here were complete blowouts all of us on
the contiki tour have spent close to a
month together we wanted to make the
most of the last nights on the trip so
we went hard for better or for worse no
food it exists cuz I didn't want to risk
my camera and then it was time to calm
things down as he went back to my
starting point LA and before we all
finally parted ways I decided to have
one last chat with a couple of people
that travelled the Contiki tour with me
some Australians this time hi my name is
Jess I'm 20 miles from home
what I most about Cody he was all the
Australian people and what I like best
about my hometown is the local music
scene because everyone knows everyone
and it's always a kick on no matter what
day of the week it is and what I like
least about my hometown is is really
small and it's really cool and the last
person I had a chat to was Emily
unfortunately my camera deleted all the
official footage of her and her
interviews so the footage that we have
remaining is not the greatest to say the
least
that was pretty ridiculous even though
that footage is all you had to go by she
was an awesome person to get to know and
so is everyone else on the contiki tour
so that is it 2 months 19 cities and
over 5,000 kilometers of driving all the
people I met and all the things I did
and all the places I traveled to it all
added up to be an epic trip and thank
you guys for sticking around and
watching till the end and getting a
taste of my experience I hope you enjoy
that or at least learned something from
it so for all you Americans out there
you guys have a pretty cool country I'll
leave you with this
you
see
me
Oh
when you keep
you